do you think super delegates are the
jedis of the galaxy or they more like
the stormtroopers oh gosh oh gosh they'd
have to be the jedis
we're over four thousand delegates have
crowned Hillary Clinton the Democratic
nominee that means the Bernie Sanders
insurgency will have to put up but
certainly not shut up even though she
won more votes nationally Clinton owes
her success some say to super-delegates
those party gatekeepers responsible for
keeping the party's integrity intact
they can vote for whomever they want
whenever they want and whether or not
their voters want more than eighty
percent of them support clinton so who
are these super delegates and are they
on the side of democracy or are they
more like super villains out to destroy
it what do you do in your spare time
when you are not incinerating democracy
it's really sexy right now that there's
a presidential campaign but over the
four years that I've served on the
committee we show up and do really
boring things that are necessary to make
our party work so you can't light things
on fire with your mind
not yet can you like walk through walls
or
do have eyes on the back of my head I
mean I
mom I ok yeah a lot of super-delegates
will say that they're like Professor X
you know they're trying to help the
Democrats others wouldn't see you as
magneto you're wielding your power just
to get more power I believe in systems I
believe in stability i would say that
i'm more of a professor x they may not
actually have superpowers but all three
did pledge their vote to clinton long
before the first primary vote was even
cast i think it was probably a year ago
so is that part of your superpower that
you can see into the future a year and
know what the political landscape is
gonna be I think she's the best
candidate she's the best choice if I had
your superpowers man you can
whoa however you want whenever you want
a year ago you already Pleasure Clinton
I don't believe in sitting in the
sidelines I want to be in the room to
influence at the Clinton campaign become
more progressive debbie Wasserman
Schultz didn't shine the bat he'll
signal to you the DNC works for let's be
honest Hillary Clinton I think it's
shameful what the WikiLeaks wrote
release if I had known it was going on I
would have spoken out against it that's
not the role of the Democratic Party I
think it's especially interesting that
you coming from Indiana are supporting
Hillary Clinton when Indiana actually
went to Bernie yeah how you justify that
it's my vote I'm
allowed to use my vote how I would like
to use it I will not be changing my vote
will these very special delegates soon
lose their prefix the DNC says it's
going to consider slashing the number of
super-delegates for the next election
something these guys say they're okay
with I think the Democratic Party has to
evolve so maybe it's too much power
maybe cut back on the numbers
yeah so you're willing to give up those
power oh yes for the good of the party
what do you do when you're not being
super I love to cook I'm gonna make a
good chili cornbread so when Hillary
Clinton says she keeps hot sauce on her
bag does that speak to you as well yeah
she she wanted me over with that aha I
guess even super-delegates have
weaknesses pandering